some employees and former employees at  the clark county government center claim  they've been exposed to toxic chemicals  causing health issues including cancer  more than 50 people involved now in a  lawsuit against the county  in some instances their loved ones are  former workers who have died  they allege the government center is  built on land formerly used by the  railroad  and chemicals were dumped and burned  there they claim clark county and the  city of las vegas haven't done enough to  protect county workers  and failed to make sure that the land  was safe the i-team reached out to the  plaintiffs in the lawsuit  and we'll have more on this tomorrow